l'accalmie a été de courte durée à
stepanakert les bombardements ont repris
cette nuit dans la capitale de la
république séparatiste du haut karabagh
ce mardi profitant d'une interruption
des affrontements les habitants ont pu
sortir pour se ravitailler constater les
dégâts civils ont fait lourdement les
frais du conflit qui oppose arménien et
azerbaïdjan loin des combats à l'arrière
de la ligne de contact la guerre reste
omniprésente à erevan le soutien au
soldat s'affiche sur grand écran dans
les rues de la capitale
de quoi faire vibrer la corde
patriotique arménienne preuve de
l'inimitié ancien qui règne entre les
deux peuples
les volontaires continuent d'affluer
dans les services d'enrôlement ici des
dizaines d'années riz dans un bureau de
recrutement de bach ou là des arméniens
en partance pour le front certains
viennent d'ailleurs de très loin pour
combattre la bête en france à strasbourg
est décédé venir il ya beaucoup beaucoup
plus de gens qui sont là déjà de
strasbourg ou partie de france donc on
est là pour eux pour protéger notre père
les enfants qui meurent là-bas on va y
aller jusqu'au bout erevan et bakou se
livre également à une guerre de
l'information
les deux pays affirment chacun avoir
infligé plusieurs milliers de pertes
humaines à l'ennemi
la communauté internationale elle tarde
à se mobiliser
le groupe de minsk créé lors de la
première guerre du haut karabagh il y a
près de 30 ans a instamment demandé un
cessez le feu
les représentants des pays coprésidents
du groupe de minsk de l'osce cee
condamne avec la plus grande fermeté les
escalades de violence inédite et
dangereuse survenus dans et en dehors de
la zone de conflit du haut karabagh les
attaques récentes qui aurait visé des
installations civiles et le caractère
disproportionné de telles attaques
constituent une menace inacceptable pour
la stabilité de la région
les ministres appellent une fois de plus
les parties au conflit à accepter un
cessez le feu immédiat et sans condition
d'autres membres de ce groupe comme
l'allemagne ou l'italie
aussi appelé à la fin des hostilités
sans prendre parti pour l'un des deux
belligérants
l'otan a fait de même tout comme l'iran
ou le canada seule voix dissonante celle
de la turquie depuis les premiers
affrontements
ankara affiche un soutien total à
l'azerbaïdjan turcophone et musulman et
condamnent violemment le voisin arménien
le ministre des affaires étrangères
s'est même rendu ce mardi à bakou où il
a été reçu par le président ilham aliyev
allemagne stone age origins et fitness a
fait de n'être l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan sur un pied d'égalité
revient à récompenser le club taurin
wiki le caire jusqu'à alger eudeline de
marne le monde doit soutenir ceux qui
sont dans leur bon voire même en
l'azerbaïdjan une position turque
critiquée notamment par le président
syrien bachar el-assad qui accuse ankara
de déstabiliser la région en y envoyant
des mercenaires syrien soutenez les
terroristes en syrie tout comme en libye
les baies roses de mai a été le
principal instigateur et initiateur du
récent conflit entre l'azerbaïdjan et
l'arménie dans le haut-karabagh d'algues
on peut être sûr qu'ils utilisent des
terreaux et syriens et d'autres
nationalités dans le haut-karabagh
hidalgo n'est qu'à la barre dont la
tante de solution diplomatique concrètes
les affrontements se poursuivent sans
qu'ils nient ce ne soit pour le moment
envisagée